ورائي بمقر المحكمه العليا بواشنطن اعلى
سلطه قضائيه في البلاد ناقش القضاه التسعه
مدى شرعيه قرار قضائي اتخذته اخيرا كل من
ولايتي مين وكولورادو بمنع الرئيس الاسبق
ترامب من الترشح للرئاسه بتهمه الحث على
التمرد في اشاره منهما لاحداث الهجوم على
الكونجرس من طرف مناصري ترامب عام 2021
ورفض الاعتراف بفوز بايدن انذاك رئيس
ترامب قال من ولايه فلوريدا في اول رد فعل
له اليوم ان خصومه الديمقراطيين حاولوا
تحويل القضاء الى سلاح
سياسي انتهيت للتو من المتابعه مرافعات
المحكمه العليا وانه لامر مؤسف ان نمر
بهذا الامر الذي اعتبره تدخلا من
الديمقراطيين في الحملات الانتخابيه راقب
هذه الجلسه ملايين الامريكيين من الناخبين
بوجه خاص بعضهم حضر هنا لواشنطن للتظاهر
ضد ترامب وينتظر بالفعل معاقبه ترامب امام
العداله الامريكيه في مجمل القضايا المرفو
[موسيقى]
ضده هناك اتهامات تتعلق بهجوم الكونغرس
واخرى بمحاوله تغيير نتائج الانتخابات
الرئاسيه هذه قضايا مختلفه ولكن من الواضح
جدا ان بايدن حاول تغيير نتائج الانتخابات
والضغط على مسؤولي بعض الولايات المحليين
للحصول على اصوات
الناخبين ستاخذ هذه المحكمه وقتا كافيا
على ما يبدو قبل اعلان قرارها نهائي يعتقد
كثير من المراقبين القانونيين الان ان
المحكمه لن تدعم قرارات مين او كولورادو
بابعاد الرئيس ترامب الاسبق من اللوائح
الانتخابيه وذلك لسبب اساسي واحد برايهم
وهو عدم القاء الولايات المتحده وانتخابات
الرئاسيه في ازمه سياسيه عميقه وغير
مسبوقه ربما تهدد حسب رايهم حاله
الديمقراطيه واستقرار المؤسسات في
الولايات المتحده سياتي قرار المحكمه
النهائيه على ما يبدو بعد اقل من شهر من
الان مصر حسين الجزيره واشنطن